greetings from [ __ ] podcast
village
wednesday the 12th of august where the
[ __ ] is the time
going you've been in lockdown for months
okay
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by expressvpn
listen i think you've seen everything on
netflix by now even the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that you can't [ __ ] understand
but with expressvpn you can trick the
computer into thinking you're in a
different country
and you'll be able to watch just about
anything in the world
i know you're bored but do you want to
watch every episode of the fresh prince
of bel-air
netflix and australia has it and with
expressvpn
you do too it works with any service
netflix
amazon youtube bbs you name it
so do me a favor protect your privacy
online today on your activity
today with vpn that i trust to secure
my privacy right now listeners of the
church can go to expressvpn.com
church expressvpn.com
church to get an extra three months on a
one-year package
that's expressvpn.com
church support the podcast but most
importantly
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
church take this [ __ ] mule lee oh
[ __ ]
it all starts [ __ ] today no more
[ __ ] excuses this is the year
of the [ __ ] soldier we're going in
like
[Music]
my girl annie letterman in the
[ __ ] house
what's happening sexy thing oh what's up
i'm decided i'm going to be a vlogger i
just decided
10 minutes before i got here okay good
how you been my love
i've been good how is this thing [ __ ]
uh
damaged you at all it's been a goddamn
roller coaster but i'm on an upswing
range
you look great i feel good you look
great so i'm enjoying the
time off the force time off how long
you've been doing comedy
11 years and this is the first oh yeah
like this has been well the longest i
took off was recently over christmas
just because the flights were cheaper i
ended up taking uh 10 days off i've
never taken more than
like four days off ever and i did 10
days with my family to the point where
they were my brother was
he was a gift of my house like
everyone's like it's weird you're still
here the girls went back to school they
were like
why is auntie still here so they finally
got rid of me
and i made my parents day too and my dad
and i were talking about we're so
grateful for that we're so lucky we had
that extra time it's like we knew
or something so we had this really long
intense amazing fun my brother has a
fire pit in the back so we all sit
around
my family smoke so we get all you know
everybody's giggly my dad likes to cure
his glaucoma
what are you hearing from philadelphia
how is philadelphia doing as a city
well my parents have not left the house
they don't leave they go on walks
um all suited up and my dad's 79 so he's
not [ __ ] around which i'm so glad
if they were the parents that are out
ignoring the whole thing
not believing in masks i would be having
a heart attack
so they haven't been doing much and then
my older brother
you know he just messed up he's a
salesman so he goes out a little bit for
work here and there but
and my sister-in-law works in a hospital
that ever working from home
i don't know maybe i'm wrong but isn't
one of your brothers like a celtics
reporter
my twin brother is an emmy award-winning
producer for the yeah for uh nbc sports
in boston is he in the bubble
did this under the bubble or no they
didn't send him to the bubble oh that
would have been crazy he's working from
home
okay but he's doing they're started
doing live shows again which is hard i
mean
it's hard things are getting cut people
you know they'll be like scandals be
like why'd you cut it off there like
we're working from our
basements nobody's planning any of these
things [ __ ] crazy
i mean and then the internet is waiting
for any because everyone's so bored
they're home so they're watching
everything they're
waiting for some sort of slip up or
mistake or something that looks
unwoke or something you know and they
wait for things and then
they pounce and you're like we're all
just in our basements trying to do our
jobs
everyone's got their kids up my
brother's got his daughters upstairs i
feel like every time i go on the
internet now it's like going on otb you
ever going to ot be like
betting it's just [ __ ] people arguing
that's what
the important that is to me now well i
try to go on there in the morning
say what i got to say post and i get the
[ __ ] out of there
suck my dick [ __ ] yeah because if not
he
i like say something to somebody a
couple weeks look
the internet right now should be
something you go to
for like a half hour because if you i
spoke to somebody
on the phone one day who was on the
internet
and he called me jacked up
people are getting jacked up on the
internet what do you mean
like fired up about something yeah yeah
about the
corona virus and all that [ __ ] and i
tried to tell him i go listen
i was hooked on the news for the first
month as we all were
yeah you know abc world news tonight
isn't the number one watch
news because nobody watches the [ __ ]
news during the coronavirus we all
watched it
at 6 30 and you know we learned about
different things
until one day i go look at my position
when i'm watching this
look at my body language i'm pressed all
the way back
like
focusing like i yeah go on my left eye
because my left eye is stronger than my
right eye
i can kind of tell now that you're
saying i catch myself like
and i go stop joey stop look at the
position you're in
look at what you look like and i go
that's it i turned the [ __ ] tv off
so i made a rule like after like the
first week i told my wife i go listen we
got to make a rule
no tv in the house for the kid either
yeah because if not
we'll all go crazy so we called it the
sixth by april
first we already had the six o'clock
rule
no [ __ ] tv yeah so six o'clock and
even then
don't even put it on until then we went
to the point where we don't put it until
after dinner
and i'm the type of [ __ ] i can't
watch jeopardy like once jeopardy comes
on that means you gotta
as comics as a human like when i was a
kid and my friends i was staying with
the runnies
his father watched jeopardy you know how
yeah the last name was the runnies oh
dull runnies
the runnies oh my god your last name is
ronnie is that sarah are you
and then they they're my family so they
took me in
1981 and whenever jeopardy was coming on
i remember i was walking past him to go
on the show
it's seven seven o'clock you're getting
ready if you're anybody
seven o'clock you get ready you're not
winding you're not sitting down watching
i do like to watch a little wheel of
fortune to get that's the one afterwards
ready to go that's the one that's seven
thousand that's what i'm really [ __ ]
suicidal
if i sit down if i sit there like that's
what i was doing
i would watch the [ __ ] 6 30 news and
be so blown away
and so scared that i would actually
catch myself sitting there
like [ __ ] anxietied out until about
7 40 and i go what am i doing with my
life
and i would get up wash my hands put the
mask on
and go for a ride yeah this is before
anything this is when it was still just
quarantined everybody wasn't angry yeah
this is you know well that's three days
it didn't last long
so that's i figured out all those things
i i i knew that right away my
in the beginning my anxiety level went
right up and i remember that
my doctor had a a heart
appointment like oh i thought you were
like if if you had a heart problem
no no no no no no would you not have a
heart appointment like march 28th
right i had no idea i had a heart
appointment like march
20th like yeah doctors are playing right
now we shut down march 16th
that was the official shutdown so i had
a
doctor's appointment like that thursday
that they rescheduled
for like two weeks later has a visual uh
uh
zoom oh okay and when i went on there
with him
like two weeks later that's when he said
to me uh
how are you feeling blah blah blah and
he goes how's your anxiety
he go i gotta go it's horrible he goes i
can tell about a look on your face
and once he sent me those [ __ ] things
like i had some at the house i had a
regular prescription from my family
doctor
or my heart doctor sent them to me the
baby one yeah
[ __ ] but i tell you what i wouldn't eat
those to go to sleep but i would eat
those in the daytime yeah
together like it was bad the whole month
of march i did that
what do you think you're oh i'm sure
that [ __ ] helped you
terrible weed is a sneaky one
i told you you asked me if i wanted to
smoke and i'm like during cove but if i
smoke weed i feel like i have
every time i eat it i go like oh my god
heart it's hard to breathe it's like
yeah you just took a bomber
bong [ __ ] rick bom bong rip
i'm not high bong
rip yeah no no the edibles i started
eating the edibles
last time i went to the store was march
3rd i already was it
when i went to vegas february 28th they
were already talking about in vegas
vegas was at 50
occupancy i did not believe any like
little esther
do you know the lester she's at the
comedy store who little esther esther
previously
absolutely she's had a special come out
by the way everybody check it out
it's so funny but she is one of my
really good friends and she
knew about this she was following
someone's account that lived in italy
so she knew about this way before anyone
was talking about on the news
and she would talk to me but she's like
are you scared i'm like i'm not [ __ ]
scared like what are you talking about
of course i'm not scared of [ __ ] like
that like what are you talking about
and then it got closer and then that
last night at the comedy store
i was on the lineup and i was like now
guys i'm not doing it
it was like that friday night right
before they shut everything down but we
knew it was coming
and i just went no i'm not and i was
supposed to be in new york
no march 9th through the
18th right i was supposed to be in new
york so my anxiety
that when i got back from
when i got back from vegas i got off
stage
on a tuesday was the last time i went
down to the store i did sam's show
and then on the way out i could smell it
in the air
on a tuesday night it's when it's most
packed or always
and it was out already people were
talking about covert but nobody was
practicing [ __ ] at the store
yeah and i was like i'm not coming down
here no yeah i was like
i knew that tuesday but i wasn't going
down there
weeks before this happened maybe even
the week before i was watching joe on
stage in the main room and you know they
just changed the lights in the main room
where they made it darker and it looked
so cool
do you remember like right yeah so i'm
watching rogan from the side
and he i'm seeing how much spit is
coming out of his mouth and i go oh man
we have a really spitty job i've never
really seen it with the lights low like
that
i go wow this is like a spitty ass job
and then
we're in a world where spit is a knife
in your throat
at this point so
we're not it's great i was just thinking
about that like when i was in
italy and all over asia i was i was
watching the news but i never thought i
was going to come here
i was like maybe but it's not like we'll
be done in two weeks like italy
dude this is crazy we're cocky we're
cocky where were we 28 when i was in
vegas and i was
in slashes bodyguard came to the show
cool he told me i've known him for years
chemo he told me that guns and roses had
to cancel their asian tour
and that they were about to only just do
mexico city
that the united states tour was still
men's and men's i'm like
what are you talking about so i got hit
with all this february 28th when i'm in
vegas
and the manager that runs the comedy
club is like
the city of las vegas it's at 50
the following week for the ufc the city
was at 14 percent
why didn't they tell us all this earth
nobody was telling you that i
and so when he told me that they quit
the guns and roses
that's when i got hip to it and that
saturday i think i went to the store
and then sunday we did the podcast
monday i stayed in
tuesday i went to the store and i
started to feel it i could smell it in
the air
i've always been one of those guys that
like when you go to a child care
like a daycare you could smell like if
you go to a school now
if you ever have to go to a school now
as an adult you could smell the flu in
the air
i mean i'm so glad that's it that was
the scariest setup for a thing anyway
you know the smell when you go to kids
i'm like oh no
no no no joey not in this climate
like when i used to drop off mercy you
could smell the flu in the air oh
they're dirty
i was a nursery school teacher i got
shingles when i was 19 years old because
i was a nursery school
[ __ ] i'm supposed to be 87 years old
when i get shingles for the first time
i got like a grown-ups problem when
because the kids were so dirty
they're dirty they can't have anything
when you go into a school now like when
i drop mercy off of their school
when you go in the classroom you could
kind of smell something
yeah something lives i know that's
that's that's smell no that's not smell
it's disgusting so i smelt that at the
comedy store
march 3rd oh i smelt it in that main
room i went to the back
and there was 15 people in the green
room and the door was closed there's no
windows
yeah i walked in and went oh and i
[ __ ] closed the door and ran to the
back door
and i stood by the back door until i
went up on stage
and then i went around and i did my
original room set and i'm like
that's it because think about we're so
addicted to what we do i mean we
like it's an adrenaline rush you know we
perform every night we do these things
and then there's been we've all had
probably those shows were like oh i
probably should have stayed in i'm
sick i should have stayed in another
night like oh [ __ ] i probably got people
sick or whatever
but you're not it's not sick that's
gonna [ __ ] kill them
and then so people don't know that yet
and then they're going in
a little sick still and they're super
contagious i mean so many people must
have gotten it
well new york did you hear the the
michael yo story
i don't know how he got it okay michael
joe was at gotham
and after we're doing the green room and
it was michael yo
jeffrey gurion mm-hmm oh yeah jeffrey
growing
big ball pete lisa lampanelli's
ex-husband yeah
i know yeah yeah and christmas early so
they were all sitting in the ground oh
my god
what a cast of characters so four of
them out of the four of them three of
them got covered
chris masoli didn't get it big ball pete
was the hospital
jeffrey gurion was in the hospital yeah
was in the hospital damn
i was supposed to be in new york that
weekend i was going to be in
nayak that thursday thank god i have
arthritis in my knee
and monday the 9th you tripped and you
hurt that [ __ ] knee on purpose
no no no no that was the hamstring in
november see i was trying to
twist make a twist i have arthritis in
my knee
and i had to go get a shot in my knee a
gel
and the next day my knees swelled up
that tuesday and i go
this is my app i had nayak on thursday
and then i was gonna hang in the city
over the weekend and then
go do the movie on st patty's day and
that monday
that was the original plan tuesday i
wake up the knees swollen
i call the doctor and he goes don't fly
till saturday
put ice on it so i took a picture of the
knee and sent it to the producers i was
just buying time
yeah i was just buying time because i
knew that
especially in new york a guy went to
italy yeah the jewish guy and he went to
the synagogue
in new rochelle is this a that's a true
story no no a jewish guy goes
to a true story he went to a [ __ ]
synagogue and he spread it like wildfire
he they must hate he wasn't giving
brises they must [ __ ] hate him in the
neighborhood
he [ __ ] that well it's the religious
hangs and
comedy he went to italy to ski
already he gets on my [ __ ] nerves he
couldn't just go to [ __ ] like every
other [ __ ] jew
to show off him saying that's to tell
people like we went there
i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
if you really want a sweet ski go to
switzerland you know what i'm saying but
no you gotta go to italy i'm not even
gonna [ __ ] get started because it
pisses me off
jewish people are supposed to be a
little smarter than that [ __ ] you're
cheap you're not supposed to go to italy
you're supposed to go to [ __ ] paramus
new jersey like every other [ __ ] jew
and ski
right every other jew goes to paramus
whether the [ __ ] uh what's it called
well i used to go to uh waterville in
maine but yeah whatever they go up
waterville is a place i think so
imagine you're naming a town you're like
hmm how about waterville
i think it's the worst name i've ever
heard can you pass me those lysol wipes
i'm getting so paranoid
why what's happening i just want to wipe
off the mic i'm just imagining
i'm sorry i think i wipe everything i
mean i trust you because my daughter
does this there's nothing
in there there's one i want to save it
for you no no take it because i got more
you're older than me you're more at risk
no
you have arthritis in your knee no no no
it's a pre-existing no so that's what
[ __ ] saved me
i know i didn't have to go they canceled
the shoot friday night
and let me tell you something i couldn't
even breathe
on [ __ ] i couldn't even breathe by
that time
my anxiety was so [ __ ] bad it just
sucks that the symptoms of anxiety are
the same as coven
heavy breathing and body aches i don't
know do you get body aches
i don't care about eggs either i don't
get bodies i just said a thing and i'm
trying to
but it was weird we discussed in the
beginning of the podcast that we all
this was good that it happened i think
we were
and this includes me and it's a sad
statement to make
i think we're all as comedians we were
like co-dependent on that comedy story
not as a living
but as like a cry i don't know what it
was i don't know what it was
and it was looking at it from a
different angle
to find out that it wasn't normal yeah
well there's always this really fun
exciting adrenaline rush hang
i mean it was epic it was so fun hanging
out in the back and the vip and stuff i
mean i would talk to joe every now we
just like i can't believe this is our
lives i mean obviously his life is a
little different than mine but
it's just i i still feel very like
blessed and lucky that this
is a thing i've done but every night
multiple shows a night
constantly having to
i i was saying to you i had so much
anxiety i didn't realize i had the
minute that
all of a sudden stand up wasn't an
option i was thinking about
how every day i would wake up and be
like [ __ ] i have to write a new joke or
i have to
you know i want to just so much pressure
on myself all the time
you know about two years ago after robin
williams killed himself
cnn did a thing about the dark side of
comedy
and i wouldn't watch it i'm like right
away never gonna start here we go
you know the dark side of [ __ ] comedy
you know
and during this pandemic i thought about
that documentary
and i thought about there is a dark side
to comedy
and we're living through it now but
it made me realize that our little thing
with the comedy store
wasn't normal it was like a mother's tit
my type of talent
like we went out during the week and
then we
we couldn't wait to rush back to the
store and i've been playing that game
for 23 [ __ ] years
and about three years ago is when i
remember i stayed out of the store for
seven years yeah
i just stayed out of the [ __ ] store i
didn't get thrown out
i didn't get nothing i just said one day
i'm not coming back down here
and i didn't go down there for seven
[ __ ] years so when i went back
it still was the store it still had the
vibe
but there was a different hair to it now
i would have fun but i got to be honest
with you honey every time i went down
there
i couldn't wait to get the [ __ ] out of
there
like there was just too many people it
wasn't
my nook anymore it wasn't my little club
anymore you know they had a
they had to put a [ __ ] bar in the
back for comics
you know and that and people still went
back there it was really annoying
it was very coming into the [ __ ]
comments it was very
you couldn't have a conversation you
cannot have a conversation at the store
anymore
you couldn't just talk to somebody you
didn't stay late enough
oh yeah you had to go down there but
then you had to deal with the drugs and
all that yeah
that i wasn't like people said i didn't
even know people were doing drugs at the
store
i just saw weed and one day somebody
said to me oh it's wait till you leave
the [ __ ] don't start here until about
quarter to 12.
you know that's when it pops off down
there quarter to 12 i'm dreaming already
i'm already like [ __ ] watching
netflix passing the [ __ ] out
so but it wasn't you know what night
became my favorite night
sunday sundays were good sunday you zip
it
but tuesday the money was great it was a
lot of fun
but it was starting to get old it was
like it got a little too big
it got a little too big on tuesdays and
i appreciate it and i'm i'm glad to be a
part of it
i was a part of history up there down
there but at the same time as a comic
it wasn't our hook anymore it wasn't we
went there to work now
it wasn't and let me talk to you for
saying we [ __ ] for an hour
it's right so you you can't have a
conversation with brogan
god forbid you have a conversation with
him and you buy a [ __ ] door
god forbid you gotta
but you got to talk about him attacking
bears that always turned into bear talk
when you went back to the store you kept
saying it was a it was right after the
season special
and he said like metal sharpened metal
you wanted to be around like really good
comics like that
how are you planning on like getting
the best of both worlds when you go back
to back where new jersey
whenever you're standing up there i have
no idea not even worried about it
i've already worked with the best of the
best i'm just looking to
i'm 57 years old guys okay i'm not
once you start getting older you don't
look that good on [ __ ] stage
all right it starts you start looking a
little bit [ __ ] embarrassing
you know i look at the [ __ ] youtube
tapes it's i'm old
so now i'm going to go up there and sell
i got to sell and my audience is young
i would feel better if my audience was
my age but people my age well don't want
to listen to my stupidity
it's just 20 year olds that well listen
to my uncle joey's [ __ ]
so do you understand the beef i'm in you
should name yourself nephew
joey so then older people come i guess i
mean i mean i
from my point of view if i was like one
of the better car
i wouldn't care if i was old on stage
but then i watched like i watched
you know you watch uh what's a guy the
guy
that you know ron
you watch my idol [ __ ] uh
red fox you know when he was on sampling
son he was old and after that he went on
the road he was [ __ ] even older
i'll go on the road so i could tolerate
it you know so i could tolerate it but i
like i said guys i don't see this coming
back till next april
okay next april february
start up slow two spots
try to work up to half hour it's just a
guess at this point we don't know what's
gonna happen there's no reason to put
energy
into the future it's like enjoying what
we're doing now people that i hate when
people go i can't wait to see you on the
road you got
you're [ __ ] saying that you [ __ ]
insane i love it people are you're right
what the [ __ ] are you what the [ __ ]
what's wrong with you coming to england
any time
yeah nobody's even [ __ ] thinking like
you you try to humor people but people
are as dumb as [ __ ]
oh and then they'll always ask they'll
go they'll go when are you coming to
colorado i'm like i was just there
before the [ __ ] thing you missed
people
just break your balls they are people
that yes as soon as you leave the town
don't wake up on monday and go when are
you coming back you're like
you stupid [ __ ] you could answer
them that but then you start figuring it
out
ah they just buckled with me
yeah who knows i don't even remember my
jokes i
i remember who they offended i remember
like lesbians didn't like one
gay guys didn't like another i want to
start from scratch
yeah i understand that i'm working i am
looking forward
to going to a pizza parlor
as an open mic i don't know when i'll be
ready
i'll call you and let you know i'll be
on my couch one night and i'll go you
know what
it's time to do stand up again
that's all i know that's all i know
right now yeah
that's all i know i know i'm gonna take
a break from podcasting
i don't know what i'm gonna do yet i
really don't
people already [ __ ] he's going to gas
digital it's like
it's like i'm [ __ ] uh tom brady now
i feel like tom brady lebron james in
the announcement he's going over here
he's going over there
he's doing a podcast i'm going to join
you to hang out my friend honest to god
i haven't talked to anybody about a
podcast at all
in fact i gotta come commend again louis
gomez
who called me and he goes i heard you're
moving to jersey
and he goes i'm gonna be 20 minutes from
you and he goes do you want to uh
how old is your daughter seven i go
my son is seven can you want them to
play together
i thought that was the sweetest call in
the world and he didn't mention
anything about i mean when i hung up the
phone
i said i love him even more
because he didn't mention a podcast yeah
don't even ask me about the podcast now
there was one guy who asked me about a
podcast and i knew he would ask me
i [ __ ] knew it as soon as he found
out he was gonna [ __ ] hit me up
and sure enough it hit me two days ago
and i said to him
you are [ __ ] predictable i go that's
why i'm moving an
hour from the city so i don't have to do
them i'm taking a break i don't want to
do nobody's podcast
i don't do nothing yeah i want to do
whatever fulfill this contract here
and just move my family i got a 10-day
quarantine period we're staying in
corporate housing
tremendous my buddy hooked it up the
whole [ __ ] deal
we sign on the first we move in she goes
to school on the 8th
check with me then yeah and i'll let you
know i'm feeling i'm supposed to shoot
the movie
the rest of the sopranos towards the end
of september
after that i'll see how i [ __ ] feel
well you don't have to make any
decisions
i think that that's the lesson that
we're learning in this too we had no
control i think we had this idea this
illusion of control we have
no control you have no control all you
have is controlling your own
moment this is great this is like living
in a twilight zone
it's been a twilight's own life yeah and
some days are good
and some days are bad some days you wake
up and have a lot of anxiety
and some days i have dick yeah you know
what this feels like
a really crazy mushroom trip or
something it feels like an ego death
with hallucinogens because if you think
about the way it's taken because in the
beginning i was so
i was relieved and then i got really
anxious and then i'm having these
moments of just
appreciating life so much more than i
would have any other time
i mean definitely like worrying about
death and mortality
you also don't know when it's going to
end having no clue when it's going to
end it would not matter
this is never gonna end i'm always like
i gotta drink more water
i'm sweating it's uh it's been like a
true it's
a bad dream it really is a bad dream
it's been a
we're a good one you know for some
listen there's always gonna be a silver
lining to this
you're always at the end of this you're
gonna go i accomplished this during this
i get it for me it was getting the [ __ ]
out of here
and i'm not like it's not because i hate
california i'm not one of those people
i'm gonna tell you california sucks or
all the taxes i'm not saying anything
about that the truth of the matter was
it was just time to go you know it was
just well all this
something opens up and you just take the
opportunity you know when i said it
i said it on this podcast in march i
said i guarantee this is going to give
people
a lot of time to think this is the first
time
people have thought since high school
since that's
i don't think in high school since
you're somewhere before college
this is the first time people have had a
chance to go
what the [ __ ] just happened yeah i went
to college
i became i went to college to be a
[ __ ] editor
and all of a sudden i'm in l.a on a
podcast eating [ __ ] edibles
i met a girl you know you meet a girl
you meet a guy
you fall in love you have a kid and one
day you wake up you're 36 you got a
house
you're a [ __ ] programmer at a company
i'm 37 i have none of those things i
just want everyone well you got 70 g's
coming so at least you got that
maybe yeah no but that that
you didn't come to any realizations from
this no i really have well
i think it's i've really realized how
much we rely on comfort and we think
that comfort is this thing we're
entitled to
when life is about adversity overcoming
things
the struggle getting through it
maintaining yourself
it's survival until you don't survive
and that's okay too
and i think that i really realize how
everything is equally as beautiful as it
is hideous so
in this situation where this is terrible
all these people are dying i mean it's a
horrible thing we don't know what's
going on we don't know what the truth is
about this
it's very anxious also i'm seeing my
nieces at home with their parents all
day
like so bonded loving each other getting
along
growing in a way that they never would
in their relationship and
i mean my it's it's really there's
things that are amazing
well i made a decision early on
i made a decision like by march 27th
i'm uh
i love my wife you know i've been my
wife for 20 years i love everything
about my wife
sometimes she bends my ear she talks to
me too much when i come in
beside that how we were all you know
when i walk in
i got bent a few ears when i walk in i
gotta pee
i gotta pee i gotta put my [ __ ] down
yeah and i just need two minutes
and in 20 years she'll never give it to
you my wife will come in and go
are you hungry and i'm like give me five
minutes isn't that so funny when you get
annoyed when someone's trying to help
you yeah
just give me five minutes breakfast in
bed out of my [ __ ] you know and my
daughter will come in
once my daughter comes in i'm [ __ ] i
can't tell her to give me five minutes
yeah
she's [ __ ] that account
but she even she doesn't jump on me yeah
that's the only complaint i have about
my wife that sometimes
when i walk it when we were together
and i'd go on the road when we didn't
have the kid
after two days of being alone three days
when i come in sunday i'd have to put
the funnels in my ear because she's
feeling jacked yeah
when women don't see you for three days
they start spilling
and you know but beside that i have no
beef with my wife
i think like by march 27th i was having
like a little nervous breakdown
in the back office and i
i said to myself for this to work i have
to come together with my wife
i can't be in this room at night i'd be
on a computer
and my wife because i would watch the
news with her and once jeopardy comes on
i'd get up or sometimes i'd go back in
there
my daughter before after the bath she'll
come out and we'll all watch tv for like
45 minutes
some stupid disney world thing but once
she would go away
i would go into my office and get on the
computer and
tweet and read yahoo and cover it and
it's affecting this
and yeah you know i was buying i turned
off the computer one night and i go whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
i had just done rogan i had just done
rogan that week so it was the last week
of march
and i figured out that for this to work
i had to come together with my wife that
i couldn't be
kind of like scared of my wife i
couldn't be away from her
so that decision made us
a lot stronger as a family that did
happen
i could sit here and tell you that
the most troublesome time was when my
daughter wasn't in school
that was the hardest period we had
keeping her entertained
but amongst ourselves we really didn't
have any struggles there was no yelling
i was really surprised
we haven't really gotten into any
arguments because i knew how much
pressure this
when somebody tells you they love you
they're not gonna break your balls
that's what i love you means that i'm
gonna make your life
as easy as possible for you as i can
that's what i love you means i love you
doesn't mean
that i bring [ __ ] drama into your
life i love you means that
i'm not going to bring no drama into
your life that's what people have to
realize someone that tells me i love you
yeah don't bring any [ __ ] drums i'm
not dragging no cats into your house i'm
not dragging no
cops into your world i'm not you know
another [ __ ] i used to do when i was 20
well i do now you know that's what i
love you means
you know that's why when i was a kid i
used to take offense like when a girl
cheated on somebody
or one of my friends cheated on a girl
because you tell that person you love
them
you know i'm saying like i love you that
means i'm not supposed to if you're
gonna lie to someone's face
any drama once you tell somebody i love
you everything else is [ __ ] but once
you tell somebody i love you
that means you're not bringing any drama
into their life at all you're going to
be the best [ __ ] friend
you could be and i had to realize that
with my wife
if not she would have been in tennessee
by now
yeah i know that for a fact it was like
we were going to drive back
we were excited we're gonna stop and see
the grand canyon
and then one about
one saturday my wife got a little my
she got busy in the daytime or something
something happened and we didn't take
mercy to the park
something and it was like 2 30 maybe on
a saturday
and that was one of the days i came out
of the office and i looked at my
daughter in the living room
and her cheeks were [ __ ] red and i go
terry
you see this she goes what and i go look
at
mercy's cheeks and she came home and
she's like oh
are you sick and i go terry are you
[ __ ] serious
does she look [ __ ] sick to you she's
going to get her out no
she was sitting there and she just
steamed yeah so after that day i go
i started thinking about it we were
excited for the drive we were going to
stop in utah
yeah we were going to stop she told me
the cities we had it all planned out
we if we left monday we'd get there on
saturday
but we had to stop five days and we were
gonna stop wednesday somewhere for like
a long period of time
and i started thinking about my daughter
sitting there for [ __ ]
from eight to two like she was in the
bedroom watching tv
and a nintendo stick and then she draws
but just that [ __ ] not running that
almost killed it like her cheeks were
[ __ ] on fire
so i go so you mean to tell me we're
gonna do this to this little girl
for five [ __ ] days where she's just
gonna get out at rest stops
i know it's just not enough and stretch
even if you took an hour each time
with three cats going meow
and disney radio because my daughter
listens to disney radio it's like the
same song
it's like the same song over and over
the same three young teenage girls
singing over and over
i sat my wife then i go listen why don't
we fly because by indianapolis i
guarantee
you'll either be dropping me off at a
mental institution
or be filing for divorce that's just too
much the little girl
that's why i didn't drive if it was me
and her [ __ ] yeah
i'm fine yeah i'd be [ __ ] i got a gun
yeah and [ __ ] drive
you know not worry about anything don't
haul nothing
you're not going to haul them if they're
going to rob you on the road
you know they're going to rob you on the
road there's people there's a bunch of
mad maxes out there right now
looking for [ __ ] to come
through their town that's what they're
looking for it's you
a girl like you in california plates
with a ton of [ __ ] in the back
they i know follow you wait it's just
trash though
yeah it's just yeah whatever come get my
empty water bottles [ __ ]
nah but whatever the [ __ ] it is that's
why i didn't want to drive yeah i didn't
wanna
i think road trips if it's the right
vibe are amazing
but if there's one yeah if there's one
thing off which a kid is
never the right if you have kids plural
then it ain't bad i don't know because
they talk to each other
they're communicating but her by herself
with [ __ ] earphones on all day no
that's not gonna yeah that's not gonna
have you gone out to nature at all
during this yeah we went to the beach
it's so nice right
you go up to ventura there's not a soul
on them
i have never experienced california like
this that's another one that's another
thing
that's the other thing that people never
really like camping up
past mammoth it was the most fun i did
mushrooms on a hike with curtis you know
the
the guy works at the comedy store he
took us on i mean it was crazy i had the
most fun
i was in i thought dinosaurs were gonna
walk by i was so beautiful i couldn't
believe where i was
like are humans allowed here gorgeous
and then and camping being in a tent you
can't understand why the homeless people
are doing like that's like not a bad
life
just being in a tense warm out pop out
go get a coffee come back but we did
that we went
um my girlfriend for her birthday i
guess it was sort of our joint birthday
a couple weeks ago we did
everyone got coveted tests and then we
went to big bear we rented a boat
it was nice renting a boat you got a
cobot test after
that too i didn't what the [ __ ] did you
get the cobia test
well it was it was over two weeks ago i
didn't get it
so crazy but
it was good it was nice we didn't go
anywhere just in the house but it was
nice
went on a boat in the open air you can't
go in the water in big bear though
there's like
toxic algae really yeah you can't go
swimming but
it's just nice i gotta take it out i've
never gotten a tan in my life i've
always been performing oh no i got
i got a third degree sunburn dude this
[ __ ] you think i'm kidding i
still got it
i still got it i do think i may look
back at this summer and go like
she had to pull the [ __ ] skin off my
back oh yeah i've been peeling
my wife was pulling the skin you should
have seen it it was like i could do
something
one night yeah i had a ball of dead skin
with lee one night imagine that's how
you get covered
oh no i'm trying to trust me he's giving
me a lot worse than kobe
please he's got his own props don't
worry about nothing
this poor bastard he wants to go to
double stop in denver and glendale
good you keep thinking that wait they
take your car and tie you up and [ __ ]
out there
are you gonna drive yeah that's not
gonna area huh
that's not a good area i don't [ __ ]
though
wearing uh glendale uh because he
he took me to denver a couple years ago
and there's this
place to get green chili and i was like
i i kind of want to stop for a day on
the ride and i won't don't who knows
when i'll be in denver again so
yeah i was going to stop near there and
get green chili or coffee
should we get green chili from santa fe
i lived in santa fe for seven years the
best
hatch what did you do in santa fe i
went to the college of santa fe which
went out of business
i went for eight years on and off and
finally graduated two years
or two weeks before the college went out
of business and um
so i went to school there and then i was
a bartender and a waitress a go-go
dancer a nanny
i was there from i moved to new york in
late 2008 and i
started college there in 2000 or 2001
september 11th happened
i was literally i was with my boyfriend
freshman year when september
so when did you live in santa fe uh from
2001 to 2008. we were there shooting the
movie
oh i was there i met everyone the
longest yard yeah
i didn't mean i was a go-go dancer at
swag remember that that club
oh my god i was in i'm in adam sandler
has a music video
um with nick schwartzen in it about it's
called secret it's about
him shaving his bush and his dick
looking bigger
i'm in that [ __ ] video this is my boy
are you i'm in the back those are your
balls
those are my balls in the video so funny
joey i'm in the background dancing in it
yeah those are my favorites that's so
funny
i've seen her balls a lot my brother
comes out i'm living at home at the time
or i'm visiting or something
and my twin brother comes out he goes oh
i got what he goes i watch that music
video and then i shave and i
cut my my balls or whatever it's like oh
god
because of that because of your balls
that's so funny that's your balls
i was so you must have shot that
the first six weeks in santa fe maybe i
mean i was there
yeah the first six weeks i was saying
were you staying at hotel santa fe
[ __ ] yeah i was there with uh stone cold
steve austin hanging out all night
yeah oh my god i walked past that's so
bright i wouldn't
i wouldn't hang out with those [ __ ]
savages oh it was fun
and i was drinking those are my crazy
days it was crazy down there
with stone cold the other big guy the
wrestlers had their own click
did you meet tate then yeah yeah that's
so funny yeah because i knew tate
for years really yeah it's girlfriend
tate um
heather yeah i bartended with her at the
cowgirl come
on yeah i worked at the cowgirl for
years sam shepard used to come in i just
have so much
remember sam shepard the playwright he
didn't work on that movie yeah he used
to
i met so many crazies
um what's his name um that was in royal
tenenbaums he played the dad
oh gene hackman gene hackman
yeah now what's her name lives in santa
fe correct
uh pretty woman julia roberts she lives
i think in pecos or somewhere
she's a ranch summer but i never saw her
in town i thought about santa
fe this time it would be fun to be
quarantined there i thought about that
too
i thought about moving to santa fe it's
expensive
really i live there seven years late
it's expensive
it's an hour from albuquerque which is
hell yeah albuquerque yo i did it i did
it
oh i love it i love that dude i went on
a hot air balloon ride
in albuquerque yeah they'll [ __ ] you i
was like albuquerque is
the is it just as hideous from a bird's
eye view than it is on the ground
i went over the cottonwood mall the
balloon took us over the [ __ ] mall i
was crying laughing it was the least
beautiful balloon ride you ever it
didn't go over the mountains at all
the wind took us over the mall was so
funny i'm in the
[ __ ] uh that's so funny dude you
probably came i was probably dancing one
of the nights you were there
i was the one with no rhythm that where
i didn't swig you never no it wasn't a
strip club
no i wasn't a stripper it was just they
had three podiums and then there was
my friend was the manager there once and
i just one night she was like here i'll
give you 50 bucks if you dance on that
thing so i just went up drunk was like
just dancing regular
and she gave me 50 bucks and they're
like come back we'll give you 50 bucks
an hour so i used to just
go dance and i was the worst dancer
there was one guy who was
there was uh like a cute little gay boy
and then there was brandy who's a drag
queen
who's calvin during the day brandy at
night so she would have like her duct
tape and stuff and everyone would come
up like you have duct tape i'm like no
i'm a girl
because it's kind of a gay club or it
was it's not there anymore but it was
the only club in santa fe so
even the one party that he's listening i
was there for this where was this
i was there for six where was the party
the party was adam sandler threw a
party on a saturday night one night at
one of those fancy swig it was that swig
yeah fancy places i went early
i got my coke and i left tracy morgan
tracy morgan was there you want me to
tell you something
i only did coke the one night i went to
tate's
tates girlfriends
oh yeah what's the name cowgirl the
cowgirl barn girl
oh my god i might have served i was
there for probably
four weeks sober maybe three
i was not there for one day sober in
seven years and i finally broke down i
go i'm not gonna get high in santa fe
yeah it's not you know and i got high
one time
i pulled an all-nighter it was [ __ ]
hilarious
the story that goes with it did you do
coke with the manager of the
bar no a little black lady no i just
asked somebody
and they came back with a package and
then there was a girl
adam sandler through a party there every
friday or every couple fridays every two
weeks adam would have a party
so the first friday we all went to the
cowgirl
yeah kate was there his girlfriend was
there
tracy morgan was there tracy morgan was
wild
tracy and nick the touro and lobo at a
table
and i remember that we walked out of the
hotel santa fe
and we saw adam didn't stay at the hotel
at the hotel yeah i think he had a house
or something
but he came to the hotel and i walked
downstairs with
tracy and tracy goes look at my man
adam and [ __ ] and adam came out of the
car
saw tracy morgan and it was like oh
[ __ ] i forgot this [ __ ] is crazy
this is when tracy morgan was at his
[ __ ] well he was also playing a gay
cheerleader prison cheerleader
way up because when we came back he
started hanging out at the store
and then he started going out with the
comics and he got thrown out of
he got thrown out of what's at the
bottom of the cienega
oh yeah strip club no
no no it's like a bar if you go down oh
barney's
barney's greenery they do catch and
you're gonna get kicked out that's the
place where you got him so he was
getting thrown out of bars
every [ __ ] night when he was here he
would go to the comedy store yeah
and come get me and i would go oh my god
yeah he's crazy he was crazy back i
remember him just drunk he had his
because he was playing the cheerleader
right so we had his shirt up tied like
that
at the club and he was crawling like
this on the ground overnight i have no
idea
i was like what and then i was meeting
it was such a funny because i you know
i'd lived in philly and then i'd never
met
that's when i when i met uh everyone i
realized because i became friends with
um sandler's chef for a while albert
i don't know if you remember him i don't
know if it's still this guy i haven't
talked to many years but i became
friends with him
and he was i remember him going like you
should be with us you shouldn't be in
this town
i remember like remembering that being
like i should move to la and i met
comedians and i was like
now that i've met comedians maybe i
could be one that delusion but then i
guess it worked out
but i really i mean that was a pretty
big deal
that was a huge deal i still remember
going to a steakhouse
um del charo or but like all of us going
to a steakhouse
and [ __ ] people were flipping out
well santa fe was the best because they
did tax cuts so we would get all these
celebrities it was so
fun you know i'd always like walk over
and just josh brolin or someone or
i mean sam shepard and i were tight he
used to come hang out at the bar
well this actually the story ends really
sadly but
um he so he would come to the bar and i
would serve him all the time and
he you know we talk and i got off early
once we're sitting there and he's like
you know i was like you know sam i was
drunk i was 23. i was like you know i
thought i'd be something by now
so funny 23. and he's like what do you
want to do and i was like i want to do
comedy
i've done improv before but i want to do
stand-up and he's like oh that's really
i would never want to do improv we're
talking like that and he goes i just
thought i would do something
extraordinary with my life and he goes
you are extraordinary and i go i am and
he goes
yeah you're gay right because my my best
friend was this lesbian look like a boy
and i go no i'm not gay and he goes oh i
thought you were gay i was like i'm not
gay
so then every time i'd say i'd be like
sam shepard thinks i'm gay i was like
i'm gonna make shirts that say that
and then i told him i wanted to move to
new york and do comedy and i moved to
new york and did comedy
and my first month there so it was like
a year later
i'm working at this restaurant next
right off tompkins square park
and i'm i'm putting all of the table
settings on the outside tables
and sam shepard walks by with his family
and i go
oh my god i go sam oh my god i go
it's me i did it i'm doing i started
doing open mics like i'm doing comedy
and he goes
did this used to be a jazz bar and i was
like okay
sam i was like but i think he remembered
me but it's like you don't know where
for you know
there was a lot of drinking back then
but it was so funny it was so cool to
see him
and i used to wait on sam rockwell and
at burr's christmas party
sam rockwell was there and i was like i
used to wait on you and he's like you
did
and then it was just like such a good mo
it was just cool
all these people i told i was going to
do something i did it good for you
i didn't know you were down there with
us is that crazy and we're in the same
but let me tell you something
i had done this
the santa fe run and then we came back
and we were now at paramount and we were
at
we were at paramount and we were at
redondo beach
we shot the football scenes in redondo
beach
training camp was in santa fe new mexico
yeah and that place that
the movie's been on every night this
week oh really oh it's on
every [ __ ] night now every night you
guys were the the football field you
used was that at a high school or did
you go down to go in the prison
oh the prison that's right the president
actually
so it was just you know when i when i
see that movie on tv
that's playing i always look watch it
for a minute
it doesn't even have to be my scene it
could be any scene
and i just smile it's changing yeah
because you cannot
imagine what it meant to me at that time
you know like i was at the comedy store
no agents would sign me
nobody would talk to me i had like a
shitty agent
no manager and i popped that [ __ ]
movie
yeah and now like i'm like watch my
[ __ ] heat now
yeah and when that movie came and i was
in the [ __ ] trailer
joey this is so exciting i haven't seen
the movie in so long i didn't even
realize
i was in the [ __ ] trailer a couple
times dude i was in the [ __ ]
when edward said it was edward san juan
i was in houston texas doing christmas
and edwin san juan called me and he goes
bro
i just went to see such and such but
they played the trailer for the [ __ ]
longest yard and you're in it
that's so exciting serious
you have a line oh [ __ ] yeah cool [ __ ]
yeah the trailer i got
that's so awesome does he ask us the
mean machine or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah something about diet coke
that's so cool that was the trailer
and something else and i was like no
way but even like you know what we did
the premiere at
kimmel's hmm and they turned it into a
football stadium
you know what hollywood high is right
across the street they turned it they
put artificial turf
that's so fun cheerleaders oh that's so
funny you should have seen the [ __ ]
premiere yeah
you know and i thought like when we were
on the set he had strippers from
albuquerque and he was paying them
they were umbrella girls oh one of the
girls
one of those girls was they brought her
go go dance and i [ __ ] up my go-go
dancing game
because she was such a hoe i was like no
you can't touch me or like guys would
come just watch her i'm like no she had
fake tits and she'll put the pasties on
her name was lisa i liked her she was
cool but she was a stripper
and she would come and it was just me
and a drag queen like a gay dude before
it was just like
i would get drunk fall off the podium
and stuff like i get so wasted
i'm not a good dad i couldn't believe
what a party town that was it's
well there's nothing else to do i had to
leave i would have died i had to quit
drinking now what was the strip club the
disgusting
oh cheeks i went there didn't need a net
to catch crabs
so where did i go i went to dinner with
adam i went to the country
the bar you worked yeah the calgary rice
in six weeks let me tell you how many
nights i went out
i went to the cowgirl twice
i went to that party at him through on a
saturday night
that's way club and i went to the strip
club one time
cheeks was not good and which was a
nightmare
fridays and saturdays i wouldn't come
home i'd get in the car
and just drive on i wouldn't go to
albuquerque i'd go into the mountains to
the house and all that [ __ ] oh it's so
beautiful because i had my own car
but to get back to your video then we'll
wrap it up
the movie had already we had shot
the football scenes already now we were
shooting like
like when lobo gets called in like we
were shooting just a bunch of interior
stuff
i think a couple people were even done
already i think like
adam was still working but like maybe
what's his name chris rock not chris was
done
and the star of the movie the original
robert reynolds yeah
and it was just a couple of us we were
going in but we were an f
series so that means you had to work
every day
so there were days i was going in and i
wouldn't do deck
like i knew i wasn't going to do deck
but they'd make me go in anyway
to break my board you never have
smartphones yet you didn't have a
smartphone yet
yeah we did we had something because i
had a phone flip phones
yeah we had so you didn't have the
internet no but we i used to just bring
like books and there was dvd players
they were reading yeah they were all
that [ __ ] i try to teach myself to read
over yeah
dude rogan okay i was in the vip room
before all this happened
and he was talking about this guy he was
supposed to work with on something years
ago
and he he was the guy pulled out his
computer and he started like typing like
this and he goes you're never going to
be a writer like that
and he's saying that to me and i'm going
oh [ __ ] i skipped typing class because
it gave me headaches the computer
so i'm like this is how i type so i was
like oh [ __ ] so over the break i've been
taking like
mavis beacon to i'm pretty much billy
madisoning myself
i'm learning from like kindergarten up
probably i'm educated
i could type in class in high school so
yeah no i'm re i'm trying to learn it
because like that was the class i got
out of
i can't do it like the way i used to but
i'm still pretty fast i'm trying to do
it but it's so hard because it's
i mean why is the [ __ ] o there i used
to use the typewriter so i'm old school
yeah
i go with the [ __ ] typewriter so we
had finished [ __ ] shooting
with just a couple of us and i went in
there one day
and one of adam's assistants comes up to
me and he drives
i hear a knock on the door and they're
like hey adam wants to talk to you
i'm like [ __ ] i wonder what the [ __ ] i
did because i was always late yeah
towards the end i can't believe they
gave you a card that seems like a bad
choice towards the end that was just a
[ __ ] up
we did 17 [ __ ] weeks guys after 10
weeks
the [ __ ] party was over yeah like
everybody was getting sick yeah after 10
weeks
like it was pads every day and our
[ __ ] tattoos and
it was rough guys this was not you know
you know every [ __ ] day
i'm not complaining i'm not complaining
but it just got old really fast afford
to drive
and like in and rush you know santa fe
was our
see when we were in santa fe paramount
wasn't there yeah
so it was a party there was nobody there
to watch it
once we came back paramount was there
yeah so now it was a little bit of a
different side
so now everybody was uh everybody was
cool now we're on the lot
now you really can't do dick so it was
just a couple of us on the lap so one
day i got a knock on the door and the
kid goes adam wants to see you
and i thought you know i go right now
yeah you know you got to drive i'm going
to drive you i go okay
so i get in the [ __ ] scooter or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah i love those golf
carts
takes me to atoms and i walk in there
playing basketball
in his office yeah the basketball court
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on there
and
adam he goes uh i forget what he used to
call me
he used to call me [ __ ] something
tony tony he's tony he goes tony let me
ask you something
because one day i was sitting with my
shorts on and my ball popped out and i
didn't know
and he walked over to me and he was like
listen i gotta talk to you about
something
that little [ __ ] uh
what do you call those bags speed bag he
goes your speed bag
is that he's popping out that's the
biggest nut i've ever seen in my life
you're like i'm gonna put that in a
music video or one i go
what are you talking about he goes your
little speed bag that's what he used to
call it my speed bag is that
so i put my nut back in my shirt and i
guess he
just stayed with him and one day he
calls me i go into his office he goes
big tony can i talk to him
yeah what's up man he goes listen nick
swanson is doing a video
and he wants to know if he could just do
a shot of your balls but i still
remember his face
and how he asked me like he was dead
serious he's like
if you don't want to do it i understand
but he just wants to do a video of your
boss
i go whatever so be it let's do it he
goes all right let me i'm excited yes
so he calls over whatever and also
another cart comes and gets me adam
and i go over and i meet nick swanson
and they actually have a camera
set up with like lights and a little
thing where i'm gonna put my balls and
hold my dick
so i had to hold my dick and just let my
balls hang
and uh what's the name of the video it's
the secret secret video okay the secret
video so for people who are not watching
it
and i'm gonna i can watch don't blink
you'll miss me
really it's that fast oh i'm in it so
fast but i have like a camouflage
mini skirt on and a black shirt i'm
blonde i got
hair like mine now this is leather but
it was a pleasure seeing you i can't
believe
that you [ __ ] your balls and i were
the fate that's brought us together can
you believe that
that is crazy it's crazy i did not that
is beautiful
i love you i missed you you had a
boyfriend at the time uh
at that time i don't think so how is a
girl as pretty as you single how all
these [ __ ] girls single
um i don't know
you want a boyfriend how do you feel now
i would i think i might want i think i
might want to have
i just can't i don't know if i want to
have kids or not i'm not at a
a place yet where i would want to have
kids i do feel
a little old for an abort i don't you
don't want to go to the abortion clinic
with your
with crow's feet it's [ __ ]
humiliating
so i you know i i but you know if
something happened i probably wouldn't
i'm at the age where i wouldn't get rid
of it were you are you
i mean i i don't even know i'm trying to
ask you are you
not sad do you wish you had somebody
during the
i mean i'm
i'm not going to comment but i'm not i'm
doing all right okay i have you know i
have
i have no idea i have an unpaid intern
right no no i'm i'm
i'm doing good i'm not alone okay good
good i thought you had someone to say
i'm not alone
a girl a girl as good looking as you
always says something on the side
get your life together uh yeah i'm happy
i'm having a relationship you look great
man
thank you i'm gonna miss you i know i
miss you too thank you very much for
coming on
my family's in philly i'll see you when
i go thank you for helping me out that
night of course
i slept that night i never forgot that i
won't i'll never forget being in the
back seat of my car
in crucial pain and going and in the
middle of all this
[ __ ] annie letterman asked me if i
wanted a blow job and i
i looked at you and you went hey you
come here give me a book and i [ __ ]
i told my wife when i got home that
night and they
she took my pants off and they saw the
blood on my leg like it was just purple
and and i go on do you want me to tell
you what the worst thing is terry in the
whole middle of this
any letterman they asked me if i wanted
a blow job let me get one of the guys to
give it to you
and we started [ __ ] howling and like
i always tell people like i'm the type
of guy that
look i don't i don't want to say this
i don't love it but i i love it when
somebody
i love helping people like when somebody
passes in your life
i'm the guy that calls you since my mom
died i know how it feels
but i love calling you and taking your
mind off yeah i'll ask you like a creepy
question
like did you did she leave you anything
in the will yeah you know like
you go joey what kind of quest oh it's
[ __ ] joy and then you'll go yeah
thank god you did that like a week later
you go you don't know what it meant to
me you made me laugh because
you take yourself away you really do you
know
so that night i was in so much [ __ ]
pain
and i didn't know what had happened i
thought my leg was broken i thought my
femur was broken
that was a [ __ ] up i thought there was
so many things that were broken
yeah and in the middle of all that you
came over and made me laugh my ass off
and for that i'll never [ __ ] forgive
you
so you ever need anything you want to
bind you [ __ ] put a smile on my face
yeah i need
tragedies i'll come make fun of you it's
tremendous you saved the [ __ ] night
thank you
anytime honey don't forget annie
letterman is also on patreon
yeah head up it's just patreon
annie letterman and then hit me up on
instagram
and i have a podcast on my youtube
channel called me inspiration but my
youtube channel is just
also annie letterman okay you're
beautiful man
keep doing what you're doing i love you
don't give up and when you come back to
philly give me a call
i will ever you're an hour [ __ ]
away this girl's but you're moving to
jersey rogan's going to texas whitney's
got pink hair
everything's going nuts everybody's
going nuts thank you very much for
coming on
i love you thanks lee thank you listen
you've all been locked down for months
like i said in the beginning i think
you've watched everything on [ __ ]
netflix
everything but with expressvpn you can
trick the computer into thinking
you're in a different country and you'll
be able to watch just about anything
in the [ __ ] world i know you're bored
but do you want to watch every episode
of the fresh prince of bel-air
netflix in australia has it and with
expressvpn
you do too it works for any service
netflix amazon youtube
bbs choose from over a hundred countries
listen to me man my wife has this
expressvpn this is tremendous why
my wife watches all the english stuff i
don't watch that that she likes
likes all that funny english stuff i
don't watch it she's probably watching
it very [ __ ] now as we speak
with expressvpn you can unlock thousands
of movies and tv shows
that are only available in other
countries expressvpn is ridiculously
fast
streaming hd no buffering and it works
for every person and device in your home
can you [ __ ] believe that
it's easiest pie to use even for a
[ __ ] momo like me
just push one button seamless so protect
your online activity today
with vpn that i trust to secure my
privacy
right now listeners of the church can go
to expressvpn.com
church again expressvpn
dot com slash get an extra three months
free
on a one-year package that's
expressvpn.com
church support the podcast but most
importantly protect yourself
at expressvpn.com i want to thank you
[ __ ] for supporting us in our
last few episodes here
these episodes have been a little rough
to do but hey
you got to do them more men here you
know what i'm saying i love you guys
wash your [ __ ] powder your balls it's
going to be a hot week
take this [ __ ] mule league
[Music]
you